yesterday's press briefing with donald
trump
was outrageous his mind seemed to
sort of turn to mush before our very
eyes with bizarre
claim after bizarre claim i'm going to
give you
very little lead up and just get right
into the clips i've gotten some
complaints recently david get to the
clips talk about them after
so let's just do it clip number one yeah
please jeff thank you sir i'd like to
ask you a question about something you
said in bedminster as well
he said that you're planning to issue an
executive order to
ensure that health insurance companies
prevent or cover people with
pre-existing conditions and you said
that that had never been done before but
that's
that's not the case because that is the
law under the affordable care act
so my question is why do you need to
issue an executive order for law that
has already existed
i didn't say i said as an executive
order i as you said
said as an executive order it hasn't
been done before we want to
we want to be able to assure people
that pre-existing condition is always
taken care of
this is truly one of the dumbest things
i've heard trump say
and jeff mason you might remember i just
dealt with this yesterday
on the show jeff mason the reporter is
spot on pre-existing conditions
are already covered in the united states
they've been covered for 10 years they
must be covered by health insurance
companies you can't be denied coverage
because of pre-existing conditions
because of obamacare we do not need an
executive order
for something that's a law and trump
comes up with this idea and as you can
see when he's pushed to come up with
stuff on the spot it doesn't go well
trump says well i want to redouble it
because it's never been mandated
by executive order so we just want to be
like extra sure
this is absolutely ridiculous this is
like saying
you know murder is only illegal by law
we've never outlawed murder by executive
order
we we sort of need an executive order
from a president against murder because
otherwise we only have a law
against killing other people we don't
have an executive order
i i have a hard time imagining a dumber
argument for why you would need an
executive order for
something that's already the law tax
fraud is only illegal by law
why hasn't trump passed an executive
order saying
we are not going to allow tax fraud in
the united states
it makes it's as dumb as it sounds okay
let's continue now on the topic of a
hundred and sixty thousand
american deaths uh due to coronavirus
if 160 000 people had died on president
obama's watch do you think you would
have called for his resignation
no i wouldn't have done that i think
it's uh
i think it's been amazing what we've
been able to do if we didn't close up
our country we would have had
one and a half or two million people
already did
we've called it right now we don't have
to close it we understand the disease
nobody understood it because nobody's
ever seen anything like this
so the question is a good one if
coronavirus
hit when barack obama was president and
we had a hundred and sixty thousand
deaths
would you donald trump be calling for
the resignation of barack obama and
trump says no
and of course there's a tweet for
everything there's actually four or five
tweets but just to show you one
donald trump did call for barack obama's
resignation
because one guy with ebola got into the
united states
through an american airport trump
tweeted back in 2014
days before the 2014 midterms and you
might remember that
the day after the 2014 midterms we never
heard another word about ebola because
it actually was not
an outbreak of any importance in the
united states
trump said if this doctor who so
recklessly flew into new york from west
africa has ebola
then obama should apologize to the
american people
and resign but resign over 160 000 dead
no he would never call for that because
why
it's trump this time that's actually the
only difference
next again with 1917.
listen closely to this one the closest
thing is
in 1917 they say right the
the great the great pandemic certainly
was a terrible thing where they lost
anywhere from 50 to 100 million people
probably ended the second world war all
the soldiers were sick
uh it was a that was a terrible
situation and
so again with the 1917 stuff now of
course the 1918
flu was in 1918. we've interviewed
uh historians who are experts in the
1918 pandemic
i asked in very clear and simple terms
is there any logical reason you can
think of
why donald trump would call it the 1917
flu
no reason that we can think of but then
trump says
the 1917 flu which is really the 1918
flu
probably ended world war ii now you
if you are even remotely connected to
time
and the fact that it moves forward as
far as we know
with our human understanding of it um
world war ii was decades
after the 1918 flu pandemic i can't make
any sense of it maybe he meant world war
one which would also be wrong but at
least it would be in the ballpark
in terms of the right decade trump asked
about
100 000 kids nearly 100 000 kids
testing positive for coronavirus in the
last
two weeks of july that's a very short
period of time and trump insists
schools should open and yes he insists
that children
are basically immune to virus
97 000 children tested positive for
coronavirus in the last two weeks in
july according to the
american academy of pediatrics does that
give you any pause
about schools reopening for in-person
learning
because they may have as you would call
it a case it may be a case but it's
also a case where there's a tiny it's a
tiny fraction
of death tiny fraction
and they get better very quickly
yeah they have they may have it for a
short period of time but that as you
know the
the seriousness of it in terms of what
it leads to
is is extraordinarily small very very
much less
than one percent believe that children
are essentially yeah i think that for
the most part they do very well i mean
they
they don't get very sick the truth is
that every week
we learn more about kids actually being
very efficient carriers
of coronavirus now some get very sick
it's not that common that's true
but kids can be huge vectors of
spreading the disease and in fact there
was a
i don't know now if it was like a it
might have been a
some kind of christian summer camp but i
don't remember exactly somewhere in the
midwest
and they had a big outbreak and as they
tested the kids
the younger cohorts had more and more
coronavirus
so you know if you take like the 13 to
17 they had less than the 12 to you know
8 to 12
and then the really young kids had even
more so this appears to be completely
wrong
but the facts don't matter they really
don't matter
and unfortunately it's not just to trump
that they don't matter they don't matter
to his followers either
so now let's get to trump's new strategy
to try to say how great we're doing on
coronavirus i'm not going to tell you
what you're going to see here but see if
you can spot
the strategy including the short term
and the lab tests
lab tests take a little bit longer and
dr burks was telling me a little while
ago that we're down to two days and two
and a half days on
getting your result on the lab test the
other ones you get them in five minutes
to 15 minutes so that's
exciting but countries in every
continent are
seeing increases in cases in recent days
cases have rapidly increased in japan
and australia unfortunately
and they're now experiencing higher
peaks than they did in march
to the south of a border of our border
cases have continued to surge in mexico
central america
argentina colombia peru brazil and
throughout latin america it's really the
hot spot
it's posing a major challenge for
this continent latin america is now the
region with the
most number of confirmed cases by far
despite a
relative scarcity of testing so trump
mentions japan and australia japan and
australia are having second waves
so everybody's in trouble and the u.s
really isn't that bad off
there's actually a lot here to
understand
so first of all when you look at a
country like australia
australia has as of this morning 331
coronavirus deaths total
that number is maybe giving you a double
take could that really be true yes
total 331 australians have died from
coronavirus
we often have 500 deaths in one day
a thousand deaths in one day 1500 deaths
in one day at the peak we had even more
australia does have a recent uptick in
cases
but only up to a few hundred cases per
day we have
40 000 cases a day 60 000 cases a day
80 000 cases a day but the real
difference
is that australia has immediately
started shutting back down and extending
guidelines whereas in the united states
when we have 40 60 80 000 cases a day
you get people parroting talking points
like we have a lot of cases because we
test
so much and we certainly don't need to
close anything
trump mentioned japan very similar japan
has a population of 125 million
uh that's about 35 percent of the
population of the united states okay
um they have a thousand deaths total
total okay
per capita japan's death rate is
dramatically lower than the united
states and trump is right
japan is seeing more cases over the last
10 days
they have a fraction of the cases we do
per capita
and they are immediately expanding
guidelines and shutting
things down so comparing the us to
australia and japan
first of all has to be done on a per
capita basis but most importantly
they are seeing cases go up and they are
shutting down because they are taking it
seriously
we are not one little clip here about
car companies check this out
12 million or 12 million above
expectations which is pretty remarkable
today we had great reports on new job
openings and there's clearly a housing
boom which has been
incredible numbers in both housing and
an
automobile boom we've rarely seen
anything like it and it's going on right
now in america
inventories are at rock bottom used car
sales are at record levels
and we will have rebuilt we're doing
a rebuilding like nobody's ever seen
it's a big plus for manufacturing and
construction
so construction's getting close to
record
territory manufacturing is doing very
well the car companies are doing great
very happy for michigan the state of
michigan we have a lot of car companies
moving in a lot of plants are being
built and expanded in michigan and
ohio now just about everything trump
says there
is a lie uh claiming everything is at a
record high constructions that are
everything everything is just doing
better than ever
but he makes the very specific claim
that car companies
are moving into michigan and ohio i
looked around
i was able to find no evidence of that
and you know there really aren't that
many automakers so when you make a claim
like
automakers are just moving into michigan
and ohio and opening stuff up
it's really easy to fact check because
there aren't that many automakers
quite frankly and again a provable lie
here's one will where i'll introduce a
little bit more
trump got an actual policy question that
was not just
kind of rant about coronavirus for two
minutes and
um he just can't discuss policy in any
depth whatsoever he has nothing to say
this is a brazilian reporter check this
out
did you ask the us ambassador in brazil
to focus his efforts
in eliminating ethanol tariffs in brazil
you have to you can't yeah ambassador in
brazil to focus his efforts to lower to
eliminate ethanol tariffs
in brazil we haven't really discussed
that too much but
at some point we probably will be and we
don't want
people tariffing us and if they tariff
us although i must tell you have a very
good
relationship with president bolsonaro
he's great he's and i hear he's doing
well he's recovered from
having coveted having coveted 19 as they
say
and that's great and send in my regards
i think that as far as brazil is
concerned if they do
tariffs we have to have an equalization
of tariffs and we
we are going to be presenting something
having to do with tariffs and fairness
and
tariffs because we have many countries
for many years that have been charging
us tariffs
he just mutters coronavirus
bolsonaro we have a good relationship
covid19 as they say
say hello to him for me if they do
tariffs we do tariffs
no ability whatsoever to discuss
policy in detail and then here's the
last one
trump again with his predictions about
the future of coronavirus
and people should vote like they did in
world war one in
world war ii and your numbers will be
in 90 days or less your numbers will be
very good i think much better on the
coronavirus or the china virus
but it's something you have to look
about look at and and say this is just
crazy this just came out half a million
incorrect
ballot applications sent all over the
state of virginia
so before changing topic randomly there
trump says
in 90 days things will be good this is
the guy who
was at march or april where he said 15
cases are soon going to be zero
he has no idea about any of this stuff
nothing he predicts can or should be
taken seriously and you really saw
during this press briefing
donald trump's mind becoming mush
there's
there's just nothing there there's no
critical thinking there's no analysis
there's no connection to the facts and
sadly as i mentioned earlier in the show
60 62 million 64 66
maybe 68 million americans are going to
vote for four more years if that doesn't
motivate you
to vote regardless of the state you live
in
there's probably nothing that will
motivate you to vote
we'll have more coverage of this on the
david pakman show
instagram which is at david pakman show
you can follow me there
as well at david.pakman
privacy.com is one of our sponsors and
they're giving you five dollars just for
using their free service
at privacy.com pacman privacy is a
service i've been using for a while now
i love it it saves me a bunch of
headaches it's completely free
and it's very quick to set up and here's
how it works when you pay for something
online or over the phone
instead of exposing your real credit
card number
privacy lets you generate virtual card
numbers
the payments are withdrawn from your
checking account but your
real card number stays completely
private
and you do it all with one click you can
autofill the card number in your web
browser
on the phone you can create 12 virtual
cards a month
you can set spending limits freeze them
delete them whenever you want
i especially love it for free trials
where you need to give a credit card
number
because i can destroy the virtual card
number as soon as i give it to the
company and i know i won't be charged in
the future
if you're ordering food over the phone
why do i need to give a restaurant my
real card number
if i don't have to companies don't have
to know who you are
your real credit card number is
protected from the data breaches that
happen unfortunately more often than we
would like and it's completely free
they do have a paid version with
different tiers where you can create
more virtual credit card numbers per
month cash back rewards
extra security features but go ahead and
sign up for the free service it's a
no-brainer companies can't charge you
unexpectedly
you're protected from identity theft it
costs you nothing
and privacy is giving you five dollars
to spend
just for signing up when you go to
privacy.com
slash pacman